Sports Illustrated is laying off most of
its staff the brand is going under we
got a cultural episode for you today
mostly because there's just basically no
news but this is pretty big news because
Sports Illustrated is a legacy brand
it's been around since 19 I think it was
it 1954 and now they're done and there's
an argument over what caused them to
collapse so we've got an AI Scandal and
we also have a scandal involving two
instances where they put transgender
models on the cover of their swimsuit
additions and a lot of people are not
too happy about that now the argument is
did they get woke and go broke or were
they going broke so they did a Hail Mary
to try and save themselves by getting
woke I got to be honest it it it sounds
like if that's the case your boat is
sinking so you decide the best way to
stop your boat from sinking is to punch
holes in the bottom of it and then it
just sinks faster but perhaps that is
the case